governor of Kentucky wants federal and
state investigators to look into a
deadly police shooting two months after
it happened Louisville police shot and
killed 26 year-old Brianna Taylor in her
apartment during what her family calls a
botched drug raid
Errol Barnett is following this story
there's a lot of conversation going back
and forth about you know how do we get
the truth on this the louisville police
chief says the department will soon wrap
up its investigation into the death of
Brianna Taylor and pass it to
Commonwealth and federal officials both
officers will have an opportunity to
review the investigation from there the
26 year old was shot and killed March
13th when Louisville police raided her
home
the search warrant states that
authorities thought this man Jamarcus
Glover was using Taylor's apartment for
his mailing address and has stashed
drugs and money officers later
discovered that Glover had been arrested
shortly before the raid Ben Crum
represents Taylor's family this was a
completely unnecessary and justifiable
killing of an innocent one these police
officers botched the execution of a
search warrant attorney say nothing
illegal was found in Taylor's home they
say when they busted through the door
Taylor's boyfriend Kenneth Walker
started shooting and injured an officer
his family says Walker was just
protecting their home he was breaking
Walker is now out of jail but charged
with attempted murder of a police
officer best case scenario for me is for
a thorough investigation to to be done
where these charges are dropped the
mayor says this investigation has to
help rebuild the public's trust as we go
through
issue after issue where we see
communities of color involved in
instances like this as a country we need
to do much better that includes my city
as well
now we should note that there is a
kenneth walker named in the search
warrant but the link between him and i
should say there's an Adrian walker
named in the search warrant but the
relationship between him and Kenneth
Walker if any just isn't known right now
and we should also make it clear that
there is no publicly available link
between Jamarcus Glover and Brianna
Taylor
Jamarcus is the man police believe was
stashing drugs in the apartment so there
are many more questions to be answered
in this case Anthony sure our Errol
thank you very much